first question up from jd who says dear
connecticut casanova thank you for
recognizing one of my real titles
i dated a girl for a little over five
years starting in college and going into
my first few years of working life she
broke up with me a while ago
but we continued a sexual relationship
for about one year after that
during this time i was blocked on her
social media oh man good grief
and was therefore unaware that she had a
serious boyfriend throughout the time we
were together
she sounds like a pip when i became
aware i severed all
ties recently she texted me out of the
blue and confessed
that she wants me back and still loves
me uh-huh she this love apparently
caused her to leave that guy to be with
me or to be alone
maybe i guess are you still blocked on
social media she might have another few
guys
in the corner i have a girlfriend that
is a red-blooded conservative
that i'm incredibly happy with the
question is not who to pick i know my
ex-girlfriend is bad for me
but my question is how do i get rid of
this feeling that she is right for me
and that i should be with her it's not
fair to myself or my girlfriend to be
hung up on a past lover sincerely you're
way too nerdy to be this wanted
this problem afflicts a great many this
might afflict every single guy
it's the problem of what if it's the
problem of the one that got away it's
the problem
of shall i really lock myself down i
could do this i could do that
it's the problem of infatuation which is
different than love
infatuation is when you are obsessed
with
an idea and it can feel a lot like love
i mean it can you know writers going
back to
ancient days have written about this
feeling of love sickness your heart
feels like it really hurts uh but you
know that this is not
ordered properly you know this is not
the right thing obviously in the case of
this trumpet that you you
were dating before who's cheating on her
boyfriend with you and who knows how
many other guys
uh yes you're right obviously you should
stay with your girlfriend
you just gotta deal with it buddy get
over your feels get over all the feels
man one
one thing that mike curate is getting
married
one thing that mike here i'm not i don't
know if you're ready to get married yet
or anything like that but
if you just make a decision
and say okay this is my choice i'm
making this choice as a public choice
this chickie is over and i i might still
have feelings and i might still
oh i still but what if and i might you
might i don't even mean to make fun of
you too much but
you might you might still dream about
this girl you might still think about
her you might still say what if what if
okay that's life buddy get over it make
a decision sometimes a wrong decision
even is better than
indecision though in this case it sounds
like
sticking with your good conservative
girlfriend is a way better idea
than this harlot that you had previously
been dating
but what can i do michael what can i do
i still have feelings
you can act like a man what's the matter
with you
best of luck i'm so glad
that you liked that clip i am honored i
am pleased i'm flattered if you want to
watch the whole show go check it out
it's called helter skelter's here again
it is on youtube you can ring the bell
subscribe get the notifications
hopefully sometimes these guys don't
send the notifications out for our show
wonder why you can also get it at apple
podcast spotify google play stitcher
michael knowles show you can subscribe
leave a five star review and you can
also order the number one national
bestselling book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds check it out
and i'll see you next time